blazing tires power on two wheels or one
and an action-packed program are the
matura Boden's a a 3-day motorcycle
trade fair on lake constance that drew
some 42,000 bike fans this year nearly
300 exhibitors presented more than 750
machines and some 50 innovations for the
coming season motorcycle expert on this
ilk says Germany had a ten percent
increase or some 140,000 new motorcycles
on the streets in 2014 with continued
growth projected for 2015 he's
optimistic about the coming year one of
the trends this year is the retro look
for example the BMW 90 it's 1170 CC
capacity puts out 82 kilowatts it lists
for fourteen thousand seven hundred
euros in Germany
a genuine retro classic is the triumph
thruxton ace 900 with a 885 CC two
cylinder engine and an output of 51
kilowatts it's ten thousand five hundred
euro list price places it among the more
affordable debuts this year
a modern twist on classic Italian design
comes from Ducati with the scrambler it
adds a splash of color powered by a 55
kilowatt 800 cc engine with a price tag
of not quite 800 euros at just six
thousand two hundred euros the Yamaha
sr400 is nostalgia on a budget the
fairly tame 17 kilowatts are suited more
for rookie bikers this rice burner seems
to say look I've discovered grandpa's
old bike
Eumaeus it believes more young people
are rediscovering motorcycles biking is
cool again a growing proportion of the
new cycles on the streets are beginner
models attractive to the younger
generation bikers duds have a new look
as well modern and casual with the
protectors integrated into pockets
inside the jeans
as Footwear the time-honored boots are
finally out and sneakers are in with
reinforced toes for protection there's
as much room as ever for individual
styles stylish but eccentric looks and
accessories have always been all but
obligatory for true bikers veteran
bikers are in their element here people
will pay a pretty penny for the perfect
sound this machine is the priciest at
the fair listing at four hundred
thousand euros the BMW r 1200 GS boasts
the only carbon fiber frame on two
wheels it's still a prototype with a
high price reflecting the cost of
development
the fastest bike at the fair is the
kawasaki ninja h2 are the first series
production motorcycle with a compressor
it's available only in the racing
version with a throttle opened wide it
can exceed 300 kilometers per hour and
fifty thousand euros per bike there's a
motorcycle for every taste need and
budget at the lake constance fair but
some two wheelers are priceless steve
gibson takes his kids noah and jordan
everywhere if not in the flesh then
emblazoned on the fuel tank
you